at what level could a computer even in
principle experience both the happiest
thought of its existence A and B the
bodily sensation of Free Fall how could
it even come close to this Revelation
which then led to gr and the equivalence
principle and everything else so it
seemed to me it's what it shows you is
the quality of understanding something
constrained by rules of any kind and
that's supposed to be the argument which
I've been using all the time to meet
girls will show that very clearly I mean
you have to bring in a few other things
afterwards but it's basically the girl
or theorem says that the way we believe
and what things are true in mathematics
is not governed by a fixed set of rules
we use understanding it's not the fixed
set of rules it's not algorithm a
computer is not capable of understanding
foreign
[Music]